elle moix votre sentiment j'ai trouvé le
présent la république que catastrophique
catastrophique pour trois raisons et
d'ailleurs en préambule je dirais qu'on
a la preuve maintenant que les masques
ne servent à rien sinon on n'en serait
pas là donc on met des masses toute la
journée et on voit là que manifestement
retrouve en confirmant pourquoi première
phrase qui m'a choqué le travail pourra
continuer c'est un peu maladroit dans la
mesure il a dit texto le travail pourra
continuer non on ne peut pas dire le
travail pourra continuer à beaucoup de
gens pour lequel la le cauchemar va
commencer c'est un peu différent
ceux qui ferment leurs magasins ceux qui
ne peuvent plus aller travailler
ils sont nombreux donc on ne dit pas le
travail pourra continuer si ce n'est pas
le cas pour tout le monde on trouve une
autre formule deuxième chose la plus
choquante des formules nous sommes
surpris par l'évolution du virus a
débordé conçoit débordés parce qu'on ne
peut pas prévoir encore que c'était
prévisible on va pas chipoter une
pandémie qui arrive comme ça même si
tous les romans d'anticipation beaucoup
d'intellectuels ont écrit sur la
pandémie possible bill gates notamment
fait des conférences toute l'année 2016
sur le sujet mais ne soyons pas ingrat
effectivement cette pandémie était
difficile peut-être à appréhender
en revanche deux fois à trois mois
d'écart non ce qu'on peut pardonner une
fois parce que ce n'est pas arrivé
depuis 1969 d'accord mais ce qu'on ne
peut pas pardonner c'est le manque
d'anticipation sur une deuxième fois
trois mois plus tard et enfin le manque
de recul historique sur le fait de dire
que nous n'avons jamais connu une
période aussi chahuté aussi grave aussi
difficile
je veux dire il ya 70 ans les allemands
étaient en train d'occuper la france en
1914 18 il avait la grippe espagnole en
plus c'est une vision l'histoire
complètement absurde je ne connais
aucune époque de l'histoire de
l'humanité qui a été facile et une chose
que j'ai aimés par contre si rim c'est
qu'au moins les choses sont claires il a
pris une option chrétienne de la gestion
de la crise
c'est un élève de paul ricoeur
philosophe chrétien il au moins dit
quelque chose d'intéressant sur le plan
philosophique
il ya deux écoles qui s'opposaient à ce
qu'ils disent la vie humaine
elle est de telle elle fait de telle
sorte que les jeunes sont faits pour
espérer et les vieux sont faits pour
prier et peut-être pour mourir c'est la
vision des piqûres même si celle de mon
ami andré comte sponville et puis une
autre vision créé
scène qu'il ait une vie humaine de 22
ans a strictement la même valeur qu'une
vie humaine de 84 ans et là il ya un
débat philosophique qu'on peut pas
trancher sur un plateau de télé mais qui
est passionnant moi je sais dans quel
camp je me range mais je ne suis pas sûr
d'avoir raison et dans quelques mois je
pense que 22 ans est fait pour vivre et
84 ans on peut éventuellement s'en aller
ce qui va mal moi je mange dans le camp
non mais vous avez raison mais c'est une
option philosophique est oui on peut
parler là dessus pendant dix heures je
ne souhaite pas la mort des gens je dis
que ces deux écoles philosophiques qui
s'opposent et il a au moins choisi la
sienne qui à la fois politique et créer
religieuse est allé respectable à gâteau
qu'on ne serait pas aussi dithyrambique
que laurence est pas aussi dur que yann
j'ai trouvé la locution inutile parce
que tous les faces il valait bien nous
dire ce qui va se passer
oui mais en fait c'est ce même si ça
même si ça transpirait sur les réseaux
etc
on avait besoin de l'état tous les
français attendent c'est de savoir les
annonces que va faire le gouvernement
dans le détail de maintenant on va
revenir sur le détail tout alors bien
sûr là dans deux condamnées patientent
les questions vous qui regardez les
réseaux cyril vous le savez tous les sms
que vous recevez c est ce que moi je
vais pouvoir continuer à travailler ça
de la bocca heureuse tout le monde
travaille exactement c'est encore et que
ce travail doit continuer c'est fou
comment flou et moi naïvement j'avais
espéré un veut peut-être d'humilité ou
de transparence du président de la
république qui n'est pas aveugle et qui
n'est pas non plus foncièrement
prétentieux ou pédant qu'on a pu lui
reprocher ces derniers mois la grande
majorité des français ont reproché au
gouvernement un manque de cohérence
un manque
un manque de fermeté et de lisibilité
dans sa gestion de cette crise sanitaire
on sait que c'est extrêmement difficile
j'aurais aimé qu'un moment dans son
discours ils prennent la responsabilité
de ces incohérences et qui disent
effectivement on est les premiers à être
complètement dépassés par ce qui se
passe cette décision a été mal prise au
à ce moment là on n'aurait peut-être pas
dû faire ça on le sait on s'excuse
maintenant regardons en avant j'aurais
aimé qu'ils qu'il reconnaisse sa part de
responsabilités dans cette gestion c'est
partout pareil dans tous les pays
d'europe
mais angela merkel arrive devant la
gambie émerger été débordé je m'en
excuse ans que j'ai mal agi